republican lawmakers in texas demanding
answers from the department of homeland
security over a reported plan to bust
migrants from overwhelmed border
communities and bring them into cities
and towns
further inland from the border
the lawmakers warning many of these
towns they do not have the resources so
let's bring in tom homan former acting
ice director he's also a senior fellow
at the immigration reform law institute
and a fox news contributor tom it is
great to have you here with us today
always good to get your insight on this
particular subject and so now we have
these illegal immigrants coming in
going to towns inside the country a lot
of them don't speak fluent english
they'll have problems
accessing resources
these cities are already dealing with
homeless issues isn't this just going to
make the problem worse it's going to
make the problem worse because they're
they're creating an efficiency that
you're not going to be detention very
long you're not going to be in border
patrol facility very long we're going to
get you into the interior to the final
destination quicker which is only going
to bring more
this all these things the department is
doing and talk about this for a year
they send a resource to the southwest
border process and released quickly why
because when the fox broke that when fox
broke the story on the haitians on the
bridge fifteen thousand nations under
the bridge that was a bad story for the
administration so they're trying to
manage the optics of the crisis they
don't want to appear there's a crisis
because the secretary to the states
there's not a crisis so separate them
spread it out so there's no overcrowding
so there's nothing to see here that's
the only thing this administration has
done they haven't done one thing no
enforcement strategy and i wish the
lawmakers asked secretary one simple
question what is your strategy
how do you want to enforce the law
because i heard him say how he's going
to force law or what the strategy is
what's the long-term plan so when dhs
puts these illegal migrants who are down
on the border kept in these detention
facilities on a bus and sends them to
local communities elsewhere through
texas or california or arizona or maybe
even points north of that what kind of
an assessment do they do on what the
impact will be to that community before
they drive that bus in that direction
great question because uh bill mollusion
broke the story a couple weeks ago
they're in such a hurry to release
people they're not waiting from betting
from the bureau as you know there's a
case where they they released a a a male
alien from texas facility
uh the vetting did get back for two days
so they released them when the vetting
came back he was hot on the terrorist
watch list and it took ice a couple
months to locate and arrest him now how
many more like that and i keep going
back to the 800 000 got aways right that
we know there's eight hundred thousand
recorded got aways because they're on
camera or they're on drone traffic we
got videos of them board children
respond they've arrested people from 161
different countries some of those
countries sponsored terrorism terrorists
don't want to be arrested how many 800
000
came into this country and there are no
respected terrorists going to do us harm
that's the issue but now we even know
those in custody are being released so
quickly vetting isn't properly done and
they're releasing people with positive
hits there isn't time to do the proper
vetting so i want to bring up some
numbers now we're talking about uh
you're mentioning all of these numbers
let's take a look at uh the numbers from
may which i believe are record-breaking
numbers if we can put that up on the
screen uh 239
416
and look at this fiscal year 2022
i mean these numbers are just
unbelievable how does it stop
well look at the total lucky you can't
enforce the law if they want to stop
turn on the turn on the trump policies
people are going to say we want about
president trump they say his policy is
inhumane he gave us the most secure
border in my lifetime illegal
immigration down to a 40-year low down
83 to 90 percent the border was locked
down and when the borders lock down you
save lives
though this administration since joe
biden become president has 2.9 million
encounters add to that the 800 000
that's 3.7 million people crossing the
border that is beyond anything i could
imagine that's historic numbers right
but
biden says his policies
are humane and i argue because
record number migrants have died on the
first year joe biden more than any year
i can remember over a hundred thousand
americans have died from the drugs are
born across the border because seventy
percent of the borba trees are no longer
in line
cartels are making billions the sex
trafficking women children are sky high
his policy is inhumane trump policies
not only humane they save lives they
protect our sovereignty in the four
years trump was president we arrested an
average of three people on the terrorist
watch list three joe biden already had
50 15 known inspected terrorists in a
year and a half so you mentioned tom our
members of congress asking alexander
mayorkas about all this congressman
august fluger from texas 11th
congressional district sent a letter to
mayorka's asking about a bunch of things
among the things he said because he
represents san angelo which is a town
north of
san antonio he said san angelo is a
welcoming community but the locality has
not volunteered for this mission nor are
they responsible for the burdens of the
border crisis this situation is a direct
result of dhs's short-sighted policies
that encourage more illegal immigration
as you mentioned among the things that
congressman fluger wants to know is what
is dhs's process to notify these local
communities that illegal immigrants are
being shipped there in your experience
what is the notification there is no
notification that's why they're flying
people in the middle of the night
they're trying to hide exactly what
they're doing again they're trying to
spread out
this crisis across the country so it
doesn't appear to be a crisis no
overcrowding nothing to see here so
every board is a border state so if i
don't care if you're you're from new
york or chicago or or nebraska every
state's a border state because you're
going to get a large share of those that
are in the country illegally 20 percent
of being criminals but the biggest issue
is the fentanyl the fentanyl is going to
control all 50 states ms-13 is already
in 48 states every state's aborted just
so that we're sure about this so you're
the mayor of san angelo
suddenly a bus 50 people a couple of
buses of people show up on your doorstep
you haven't been told they're coming no
you have not
well
well these cities are on notice now
well again i hope these i hope these
congressmen stand up i hope look
for day one they take congress back they
need impeachment orcas he has he has he
has ignored the oath he took he has made
this country less safe
he's the secretary of homeland
insecurity at this point because the
border is out of control
this is a national security issue i
don't care what your poli what your
opinion is on illegal immigration it's
not about illegal immigration anymore
terrorists are crossing the border we
know that fentanyl has crossed the
border killing over a hundred thousand
americans this is beyond immigration
crisis something needs to be done tom
good to see you thanks for coming in to
see you thanks for having me good to see
you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now